on some very rare occasions when it was
only going to be a deal breaker I might
take that joint so if I knew this joint
was going to go around the room and I'm
building it what I would do is I would
backload it in other words at the front
of the joint what I'm only going to put
there is tobacco I'm going to backload
it with the whether it was green or
resin to towards the back of the joint
towards the roach end in other words so
backload it Market that's one way you
don't have to actually be smoking the
gear another way I was very Adept at
chopping up lines I would practice
making people's initials because you're
so Adept at chopping up these lines and
turning them into people's initials that
they like it it becomes a talking point
and they kind of forget that you're
actually not going to Hoover up a line
or two anything to actually negate the
need for me to actually take gear